oh here is the vibration leading me
where i need to go
[Music]
okay cool this game contains scenes of
explicit violence and
gore oh off oh
all right oh
pc well let's go for violin i guess
oh oh oh
oh
okay
hi everybody welcome to ultrakill oh we
have to punt
hey hey ho okay well that's
oh god my head ow
all right
oh hi yeah yeah yeah
i love this deal close range damage to
douse yourself in fresh blood
this is the only way to regen health
okay
i'm guessing it has to be fresh blood oh
this is nuts
oh this is nuts oh
man i love
i love it oh
oh
oh oh can't slam so apparently i'm in
hell
which is cool i'm not i'm not too too
opposed to that
this is one of the highest rated games
on steam right now
by the way legitimately it's it's like
top
five and uh i'm starting to see why
the style is nuts give me that gun
all right
okay okay okay
ah no you don't oh my god actually they
hurt a lot
okay give me a second guys starting to
get used to it
into the fire i love it though this is
nuts and a half
how do i get through there
yeah oh oh
[Music]
that's so cool all right i'm not going
to get any more secrets from now on but
that was really dope
dope i say
dope i say bam
secrets all right
oh definitely don't want to hit that
[Music]
this is so cool oh my god this is
awesome
oh never mind okay apparently death is
actually possible
okay cool i'm ass distinct hell yeah
there's a secret in here definitely
there we go wait wait for it
hello hi ah i
love everything that's happening here
it's so cool
oh you're creepy though nice
oh my god
punch the projectile to deflect it oh
do it again
[Applause]
whoa oh yeah give me your blood
you know this is the kind of game that
will get you put on some lists
but uh you know why never mind i'm an
idiot oh okay yeah yeah
oh let me in there
oh god i'm an idiot oh i can't double
jump that's what's really throwing me
usually in these types of game double
jumping is definitely not
a thing i guess bam boom something going
on here
what do we got going on here yes hello
oh god nope that's not good so how do i
get over there
oh that's easy yeah cool i'll deal with
it
oh my god hey how you doing
oh
yeah so um this game is one of the
highest rated games on steam right now
and i can
whoa whoa what are you
doing
malicious face yeah you know i can kind
of see oh boy i don't think i could
dodge that
ow ow oh oh your face got militialized
hey how you doing there stupid idiot i
am low on blood
if this is hell man hell's right
all right that's fair yeah i get that
man i missed two more secrets i knew
there had to be something there i don't
know what i did with my pee
all right i got 11 949 p get five kills
with a single glass panel
didn't i do that maybe i i didn't do it
on one of my not restarts so that's
probably fine
use your points in the shop at the start
of each level with new equipment ooh
it scan weapon like a revolver do
locational damage headshots deal two
limb shot deals 1.5 okay
a marksman alt fire to throw a coin hit
the airborne coin to deflect your shot
into the nearest enemy's weak point
coins can be chained
okay weird the cyber grind is an endless
survival mode good performance gives
many points
progress in the current mission will be
lost i'm okay i'm still enjoying what
i'm doing right now so i'm just gonna
keep at that
hey bud prelude second meat grinder yeah
i'm sure it is
hey what did the oh god ah
idiots stupid oh
you fools falling right into my yeah
whatever
i guess they're dead so there's no point
in gloating hey what's up hey what's up
oh missed you though hey stop it
nice and architect that's probably
secret in here definitely a secret in
here
huh ah there it is there it is
there she is
hey oh
hey bud wow
you look cool see bud
is that me is that well i mean is that
one of me probably not as cool as i am
probably way cooler enhancement hey come
back i want to be your friend
hey come back you sure are leaving a lot
of bodies around here i sure wish i had
a sword like that
buddy hal buddy pal
buddy pal hell buddy oh hey
there's some there ah
okay okay okay
hey what what is this what do i do about
this what do i do about this
what do i do about this what do i do
about this i've got a hand here
i don't know what i did what did i get
what did i get oh
okay
[Music]
oh my god okay i punch him with the
skull now
this is what i do oh
yo you would be scary if you were
actually oh hey buddy
oh did i just kill my buddy oh no i just
killed my buddy didn't i
ah [ __ ]
buddy there goes my buddy yeah
oh no they were just so fast i guess i
should have known that i wouldn't have
killed him
hey that looks oh what that do
what'd that do i did something cool
oh was i supposed to do that god damn it
i thought it was something cool
sure that's good beat the secret
encounter did i do that
did i do that all right i'm just gonna
try the endless mode after the oh i
found a secret never mind
give me that i'll take it
horror game something wicked this way
comes horror game
oh no what the hell
what the hell happened this is bizarre
i don't know if i'm going the right way
i don't know how anyone would know if i
can go in the right way
oh here we go did i do it
oh i see i see i see
right right no
no thank you oh my god
oh my god are you kidding me
you can't just suddenly become a horror
game
you can't just turn into a horror game
oh wow i don't know where i am
hello okay
you can't just suddenly become a horror
game
i guess
i guess i am in hell
oh my god where are you oh no oh my god
okay so i can kill him definitely i just
need to light up my path
my path give me my path my path my path
my path
okay just gotta find all the pillars
i hear you i hear you
oh no no no no where are you i don't see
come at me bro get
out of here oh here
is the vibration leading me where i need
to go
all right well oh ha ho
hee ho now that i know the secrets you
ain't so scary
you ain't so spookalicious you ain't so
spooky
oh my god my reflexes are just too good
you'll never be able to beat me
man hell is not fun you know i'm gonna
go ahead and say that
i know it's a bold claim to make but i'm
just gonna go ahead and declare that
hell ain't so
fun little uh terrible actually if i had
to put it into words
quite a word
i got you i got you i got you what if i
can punch him
probably a good idea i'll just
constantly shoot how about that
they're just they're just so thin
they're hard to shoot but i can get them
oh found it oh boy
hey oh am i out am i out oh my god i'm
out i'm out i'm out baby
mankind is a failure free will is a flaw
let the evil of their own lips consume
them then i shall begin again with my
word as
law god is this your writing
i recognize your handwriting anywhere
also i'm a robo
okay so wow yeah something wicked no
what the hell okay so what i'm gonna do
now is i'm gonna try the cyber grind
some kind of endless mode okay terminal
is used for cyber
grinder customizations
whatever let's just try basic if blown
too far off the arena pump charges
overcharge is a good way to get back
i'm sorry all right whatever let's go
for it
oh that's what light mode means my
freaking eyes oh okay
all right okay
no ah whoa hey
none of that none of that
yeah oh my god okay
okay all right oh you're different but
you're very different
nice good job me thanks me
oh wow this is super cool by the way
i don't know if you get that from me
playing this but this this game is just
super cool it's so stylish it's just fun
like oh my god and apparently there's a
lot of actual gameplay value in here
oh i'm astistic i love it i actually
love it
oh my goodness gracious
whoa who's got that for oh hey whoa none
of that
ow can you give me some blood please
spare a little blood for the bloodless
sir may i have some
blood whoa
super cool oh got you
i don't [ __ ] if that guy's powerful or
something whoa yes
who's screaming oh it's faceman oh he's
angry
love it hey freaking love it
what oh
my god
yeah i agree man i agree oh hi
someone spawned in me
oh my god give me your blood give me
your blood give me your blood
oh god don't give me that blood ow hey
stop it
oh my god
oh god it's another me oh my god it's
another me
it's fine oh my god
where am i where am i oh god
oh god oh god you're scary
oh he's tough he's dead now so what does
it matter
oh hey oh god okay
oh my god okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay
oh my god i'm gonna die okay yeah that
one was tough i probably could have
climbed the walls but i didn't think
about him
literally just now i like that though
this game is freaking dope
it's just cool that's it that that's it
it's cool
but back into the ground now let me try
this other weapon whatever this is
the marksman oh so i can do both okay
so this is something about key
right interesting
interesting okay all right so the same
basic principle but the all fires
different
okay
damn well that's a bit that's tough to
get used to okay
i know you're eager to get my blood but
i'm either eager to get yours
all right there's definitely got to be
what are these beams of light all about
there's something up there i can see
that
[Music]
nah there's no way okay unless there's
something i don't know about there's no
way
that's awfully generous about that
i guess i could just you know it's
distracting because i'd rather just
shoot them
to be perfectly honest i would rather
just kind of you know shoot the enemies
instead of shooting a coin
hey bog
who burped you burped bud who burped
down there
[Music]
hmm insufficient firepower you say
well win some lose some i guess
oh well that looks fancy hello
oh hey bud how you doing good to see you
hey
bud well that's
useless i would rather just shoot him
i would rat i can just shoot him i
forgot i have this
oh god he's mad
why do you have did he have multiple
health bars or am i crazy whoa
chabot
oh yes please this is my kind of weapon
kind of like a spray and pray jesus give
me
wait isn't this the one that gives you a
boost wait a minute
[Music]
but wait a minute
nah i don't give you a boost it don't
give you no boost
oh we do give you a boost
i'm dead though so what does it matter
whoa i'm here oh baby oh baby oh baby oh
baby oh baby
oh baby oh my god
whoa baby whoa baby whoa baby whoa baby
whoa baby whoa baby well that didn't
work
also bigger showers of blood with this
thing
i'm gonna get you you think that you're
gonna get away
yeah i thought you could sneak about me
mommy yeah you good mommy
you think you could sneak up on me
you sneak up on nobody am i going
backwards or something
i must be going some kind of backwards
holy crap what is happening here
was i'm not supposed to go that way did
i oh
i bet right i went through that door
thinking that that was
ah
oh my god yes please yes please yes give
me
round two round two big guy
yes please
ow ow jesus
give me your blood
oh i can dodge sideways that's helpful
done baby done
i probably shouldn't have done that i
don't care i feel good
i feel good i forgot how to down slam i
forgot i could do down slam i forgot i
could do down
slam pump charge too many pumps will
cause your shotgun to explode
yeah you know i know how it is
oh my god you go up so far
that is definitely exploit worthy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay just three pumps gotta remember
three pot well seems like i'm one pump
too many
show me what you got
all right i gotta stop playing this game
is so fun thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below
if you want to play this it's linked in
the description i can definitely see why
it's one of the highest rated games on
steam right now
there's just so much to pull apart here
mostly enemies in hell so thanks again
and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye